[Applaudissements]
bonjour alors je vais répondre à
certaines questions sur l'addiction au
jeu mais je vais commencer par vous
poser une question qui parmi vous se
considère comme étant quelqu'un de
rationnel pour y lever la main très bien
merci
alors je suis désolé je vais devoir vous
annoncer que en fait on est tous
irrationnel nous sommes tous et
rationnelle déjà on est des humains on
n'est pas des ordinateurs et donc nous
sommes tous et relationnelles dans
certaines situations et en particulier
les situations sur lesquelles nous
n'avons pas de contrôle donc dans des
situations n'avons pas de contrôle on va
attendre donc à penser de façon
irrationnelle c'est-à-dire à établir des
liens là où il y en a pas a projeté un
contrôle là où on en a pas
qui parmi vous ne s'est jamais dit quand
il a vu le feu passait au vert sur son
passage à super jeu passez une bonne
journée
qui parmi vous n'a pas fait attention à
marcher dans la rue sur un certain type
de pavés pour une raison qui vous
échappe
mais vous le fait quand même donc comme
je le disais dans toute situation où on
n'a pas de contrôle nous allons avoir
tendance à essayer de projeter le
contrôle que nous avons habituellement
là où il en a pas vous vous en doutez
des jeux de hasard et d'argent constitue
un cadre idéal pour ça donc dans ces
situations par nature nous n'avons qu'un
contrôle partiel voire même une absence
totale de contrôle sur la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes engagés donc la
situation de jeu et donc nous allons
projeter le contrôle en essayant
d'influencer l'issue du jeu quand bien
même nous ne pouvons pas donc c'est ce
qu'on appelle c'est un peu un mois un
peu barbare mais c'est ce qu'on appelle
des distorsions cognitives ou des
fausses croyances et donc ces fausses
croyances elles sont inhérentes à toute
situation de hasard donc en particulier
les jeux de hasard et d'argent chez tout
le monde les joueurs excessifs comme le
joueur occasionnel lambda qui
participent à
activités de jeux de hasard et d'argent
donc qu'est-ce qui différencie un joueur
excessif d'un joueur occasionnel en
termes de fausses croyances pas grand
chose la différence allait pas
quantitative lé pas qualitative pardon
elle et quantitatives ce que j'essaie de
vous dire c'est que les joueurs
excessifs il se distingue surtout par le
fait d'avoir un nombre élevé de fausses
croyances et on sait que ces fausses
croyances elle participe au maintien au
développement et au maintien de
pratiques de jeu excessif puisque je
vous en expliquer quelques unes elle
donne aux joueurs l'illusion de
contrôler et peut-être de pouvoir par la
suite gagné donc les la croyance la
fausse croyance la plus répandue chez
les joueurs c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'illusion de contrôler c'est à dire
penser qu'on a un contrôle plus élevé
qu'on l'a en réalité dans une situation
sans peuple e5 qu'on rencontre souvent
chez les joueurs c'est d'avoir un
accessoire fétiche un t-shirt fait
échouer un grigri quelque chose qu'on
emmène avec soin pour jouer et dont on
pense qu'il va nous porter chance
et bien sûr qu'on n'aura pas de chance
si on ne l'a pas avec nous ça nous
permet d'expliquer pourquoi on gagne
pourquoi on perd de façon relativement
irrationnel alors j'ai pas encore défini
mon sujet je suis venu vous parler de
l'addiction aux jeux
alors je sais que vous savez tous ce que
c'est que l'addiction
en général on parle d'addiction plutôt
en ce qui concerne les substances
l'alcool le tabac etc
donc quand on parle de substances la
notion d' addiction elle pose pas de
problème quand on parle de comportement
c'est peut-être plus compliqué
intellectuellement à comprendre de se
dire que l'être humain peut être accro à
un comportement ne pas pouvoir se passer
d'un comportement et pourtant c'est le
cas et c'est ce que je suis venu vous
expliquer aujourd'hui que certaines
personnes vont développer des
difficultés avec certains comportements
et donc ne plus avoir de grosses
difficultés à s'en passer
donc c'est le cas du jeu que c'est le
cas aussi d'autres d'autres
comportements ce qu'on appelle les
addictions comportementales donc dans le
cadre du jeu donc le jeu c'est une vraie
addiction
en quoi se caractérise cette cette
addiction par la perte de contrôle c'est
essentiel c'est à dire que la personne
qui a une addiction je ne peut pas
s'empêcher de jouer malgré sa volonté de
ne pas jouer elle va être reçue dans
l'incapacité de ne pas le faire la
dictée celui qui a perdu la liberté de
s'abstenir
donc il ya la perte de contrôle il ya
les conséquences alors quand on parle de
jeu on se la première conséquence qui
nous vient très spontanément à l'esprit
c'est la perte d'argent
la perte d'argent les conséquences
financières les dettes etc
sauf que le jeu c'est pas juste la perte
d'argent c'est aussi tout un ensemble de
conséquences négatives qui peuvent être
familial professionnel conjugales elles
sont très très multiples et parfois même
le jeu et pas du tout l'argent n'est pas
forcément au premier plan ça peut être
d'autre chose donc première question
pourquoi on devient addict aux jeux
tout simplement parce que le jeu rend va
chez le joueur remplir une fonction
c'est à dire que pour certains ça va
être une fonction de régulation de
l'humeur certains vont jouer vont aller
jouer est retourné jouer parce que ils
se sentent déprimés parce qu'ils se
sentent anxieux parce que leur quotidien
les ennuis ou les angoisses et donc le
jeu est une un espace de déconnexion et
d'ailleurs c'est pas forcément un
problème en soi le jeu est un espace de
déconnexion qui est nécessaire qui offre
une fonction ludique et parfois souvent
même sociale donc une fonction dont on a
tous besoin alors chez certains ça va
prendre un aspect excessif et donc le
jeu va devenir le seul moyen finalement
de réguler l'humeur le problème c'est
que le jeu à son tour va occasionner des
troubles de l'humeur puisque quand le
sujet père il va se sentir triste et
donc potentiellement retourner jouer
pour venir combler cette contrebalancer
cette tristesse donc première fonction
une fonction de régulation d humeur mais
aussi pour beaucoup et de plus en plus
le jeu va permettre de ressentir des
sensations fortes ce qui nous fait
parfois un peu d
faux dans notre vie quotidienne qui est
parfois un peu ennuyeuse métro boulot
dodo et c est donc on est parfois pour
certains en manque de sensations de
stimulation et donc le jeu va permettre
de ressentir des sensations qui sont à
la fois forte nouvelle excitante
c'est le joueur qui vous dit moi j'ai
une espèce de grosse adrénaline quand je
regarde quand je joue au poker et que
j'attends ma carte ou que quand je quand
je fais un pari sportif et que je
regarde la course et que mon cheval
passe la ligne d'arrivée
donc tout ça permet un niveau élevé de
stimulation qui va être recherché par le
joueur autre question importante et je
sais que vous vous la poser comment on
passe de j'aime bien jouer à j'ai un
problème avec le jeu alors pour répondre
à cette question je vais vous raconter
une petite histoire c'est l'histoire de
marque dont j'ai modifié le prénom donc
marque à 25 ans et il se rend donc il
travaille il se rend après le travail
avec des collègues qui lui propose un
jour d'aller boire un verre après le
travail et donc dans le bar où ils vont
y lit à l'offre une offre de jeux ou des
courses il peut pas on lui propose de
parier sur les courses donc ses
collègues lui dise tiens et sèche
cheveux à voir c'est amusant donc
effectivement il essaye et puis là hop
avec sa petite mise donc luminisme
toutes petites sommes donc 2 euros et
avec sa petite mise et gagne une somme
moyenne cinquantaine d'euros il détient
c'est sympa c'est plutôt amusant jeu
c'est vrai que non seulement c'est
amusant mais en plus ça rapporte un
petit peu et donc petit à petit va se
mettre à aller de temps en temps avec
les collègues
après un travail faire un bar un petit
un petit café après le travail et puis
et puis jouer et puis va se rendre
compte que bayer gagne assez souvent et
puis quelques temps après il va faire un
gros gars il va gagner plusieurs
milliers d'euros
donc là vous vous rendez compte de
plusieurs milliers d'euros dans notre
vie quotidienne ça change un peu le
quotidien ça ouvre plein de possibilités
ça ouvre aussi plein d'espoir et
finalement ça motive à retourner jouer
on se dit j'ai gagné une fois pourquoi
je
pourquoi je regagnerai pas ça mais un
petit peu de piment dans le quotidien
aussi au delà de l'aspect financier
finalement donc progressivement marque
va commencer à l'est de plus souvent
joué dans l'espoir de retrouver cette
sensation parce qu'il n'ya pas juste
l'attrait financier il ya aussi ce qu'on
ressent quand on gagne qui est
relativement indescriptible dit il donc
progressivement il va aller jouer de
plus en plus souvent donc à ce moment la
marque étant une espèce de lune de miel
avec le jeu et cette phase est celle que
kuster a appelle la phase de gains vous
vous en doutez malheureusement cette
phase de gains ne peut pas durer
et elle se sent suite de ce que ça
aurait appelé la phase de pertes
donc pour marc il va toujours avoir le
souvenir de ce gain est donc allez
rejouer
de plus en plus fréquemment et il se
rend compte qu'ils père et quand il
gagne et il avait développé ce que des
croyances comme je vous disais tout à
l'heure des croyances irrationnelles qui
l'amenait à penser que finalement il
était bon que il avait un bon feeling
avec les courses de chevaux qu'il était
capable de gagner et et puis que les
courses de chevaux c'était aussi un
moyen facile et ludique de gagner un
petit peu d'argent d'arrondir les fins
de mois voire même de devenir riche donc
dans un second temps je vous le disais
il va commencer à perdre a accumulé les
pertes et à jouer de plus en démontant
de plus en plus important avec l'idée de
se refaire évasivement et hier j'ai
perdu peut-être 50 euros lafarge a misé
un petit peu plus si je veux les
récupérer c'est 50 euros donc il va se
mettre à accumuler les pertes et à ce
moment là ses croyances c'est l'idée
d'être bon l'idée d'avoir une certaine
maîtrise sur le jeu vont être un peu
mise en échec est remplacé par cette
idée que il faut qu'il se refasse il
faut qu'il se refasse et donc il va
continuer miser de plus en plus et
parallèlement à ça le jeu va prendre une
place vraiment de plus en plus
importante dans sa vie
donc il va commencer à rentrer de plus
en plus tard à se disputer avec sa
compagne qui finira par le quitter parce
qu'elle en aura assez non seulement 2
devoir qui passe tout son temps aux jeux
mais aussi qu'ils dépensent de plus en
plus d'argent et en piquant un peu dans
l'argent du ménage
les copains qu'il avait l'habitude de
voir vont aussi finalement s'éloigne un
petit peu puisque marquez complètement
obnubilé par le jeu par plus que deux
courses ne parle plus que de pronostics
de paris de gains de pertes
donc ça finit par les ennuyer un petit
peu et puis ça va aller aussi assez mal
au travail puisqu'il va s'absenter assez
régulièrement de son de son travail pour
aller placer des paris voir des courses
et c'est donc là on se rend compte que
le jeu empiète de plus en plus sur sa
vie et ça prend un certain nombre
d'années on sait ces étapes que je vous
ai décrites jusqu'à arriver à peu près à
l'âge de 34 35 ans où il entre dans ce
qu'on appelle la phase de désespoir qui
comme son nom l'indiqué pas une phase
très marrante et donc là les pertes sont
devenus très importante
il ya souvent un certain nombre de
dettes qui se sont accumulés voire même
un surendettement et la marque se
retrouve complètement isolé puisque son
sa petite amie l'a quitté s'il a pu
vraiment d'amis proches puisqu'ils se
sont tous ceux progressivement éloigné
plus de travail donc plus de moyens
d'avoir de l'argent est pourtant
toujours cette envie très forte de jouer
de recouvrer de l'argent pour payer des
dettes à ce moment-là il envisage plein
d'issue toutes les issues à la remarque
qui n'est pas quelqu'un de violent qui
n'est absolument pas un délinquant
d'habitude se met à se demander si il
peux pas piquer de l'argent dans la
caisse du patron ou volé des volets des
sacs à main dans la rue pour avoir de
l'argent pour jouer voilà où il en est
arrivé
et à ce moment là donc l'humeur est très
dépressive
il ya des îles d'or très mal il mange
très mal vraiment sa vie entière tourne
autour du jeu et autour de cette
préoccupation des des pertes et de la
possibilité de retrouver de l'argent
pour jouer et à ce moment là il peut
envisager que quatre solutions la fuite
s'en allait recommencer ailleurs le
suicide
poussé au bout l'incarcération suite à
des délits ou l'appel à l'aide
et c'est à ce moment là qui pousse la
porte d'un centre de soins et qui
demande
quand lui qu'on l'aide à se sortir de
cette conduite de jeu voilà alors avant
d'en arriver là qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire
qu'est ce qu'on fait si on pense que soi
même ou un de ses proches peut
rencontrer ou est à risque de rencontrer
des difficultés avec le jeu déjà
première chose ça paraît évident ne pas
hésiter à en parler en parler si ça vous
concerne vous en parler avec un proche
quelqu'un en qui vous avez confiance si
ça concerne l'un de vos proches lui en
parler sans tabou sans non plus être
dans le jugement ou dans l'agressivité
mais tout simplement aborder le sujet
calmement et éventuellement proposer de
rencontrer un professionnel de santé
pour faire un point pour voir un petit
peu où on en est voilà alors donc
n'oubliez pas on est tous irrationnelle
ce qui nous sépare joueurs occasionnels
d'un joueur excessif
encore une fois c'est pas quelque chose
de qualitatif c'est quelque chose de
quantitative donc on a tous les mêmes
bases de fonctionnement
donc on est tous un peu potentiellement
vulnérables à ça et c'est notre rôle à
tous d'être vigilants et de faire
attention à nous mêmes et à ceux qui
nous entourent
merci de votre attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]